THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR FINAL
SENATE BILL HEARING TODAY IN
ROOM 2200 OF THE Þ STREET
BUILDING. MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
REALLY RESPONSIVE TODAY, SO IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
QUORUM RIGHT AWAY. BUT WE HAVE
97 MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA,
ONLY ONE OF WHICH IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A DUE PASS MOTION. THE REST
OF OUR BILLS ARE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES. AS USUAL, WE WILL
EXTEND A COURTESY TO ANYONE THAT
HAS A Dð PASS ITEM BEFORE US AND
ALLOW THEM TO PRESENT THEIR BILL
OUT OF AGENDA ORDER AS THEY SHOW
UP. ALL MEMBERS WITH SUSPENSE
ITEMS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING HAVE PREVIOUSLY WAIVED
PRESENTATION. WE WILL BE TAKING
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC ON
EACH AND EVERY ITEM, EVEN IF THE
AUTHOR HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
INDICATED THAT THEY ARE VERY
BUSY WITH THE BUDGET, AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE, AND THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON ANY OF THE MEASURES
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. SO THEY
WILL NOT BE PRESENT TO TESTIFY
TODAY. BEFORE WE BEGIN, I WANT
TO REMIND ANY WITNESSES TO LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL. PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY POLICY
DISCUSSIONS AND REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY IN YOUR COMMENTS. SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR HEARING
TESTIMONY ON THE MEASURES BEFORE
US TODAY, LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. MADAM ASSISTANCE, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. HERE.
CABALLERO HERE. JONES. ASHBY.
HERE ASHBY. HERE. BECKER. HERE.
BECKER. HERE. BRADFORD BRADFORD.
HERE. CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE.
WAHAB WAHAB, HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. NOW WE CAN MOVE ON TO
THE BUSINESS OF THE DAY, OUR
FIRST WITNESS WILL BE SENATOR
DURAZZO, WHO IS HERE ON SB 1488.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, SENATE
BILL 1488, DOES TWO THINGS, IT
DIRECTS CALTRANS TO SUPPORT
ARENA ADVERTISING DISPLAYS IN
THEIR CURRENT NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY
ADMINISTRATION. THE SECOND IS
THAT THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REDUCE
THE LENGTH OF TIME FOR A
MARKETING CONTRACT FROM ONE YEAR
TO 120 DAYS, WHICH MORE
ACCURATELY ACCURATELY REFLECTS
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING
OPPORTUNITIES. THIS PROVIDES
STADIUMS AND ARENAS REVENUE
STREAMS THAT DO NOT RELY ON
PUBLIC FUNDING. THE ARENA
EXEMPTION WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED
BY THE LEGISLATURE YEARS AGO TO
HELP FUND THE CONSTRUCTION AND
THE OPERATIONS OF THE STADIUMS
AND ARENAS, WHICH ARE IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL REGIONAL
CENTERS. STADIUMS CREATE
THOUSANDS OF PERMANENT LOCAL
GOOD CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND
GENERATE MILLIONS IN STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES. THE UPDATE IN
MARKETING AGREEMENTS REFLECTS
THE EVER CHANGING MODELS OF
ADVERTISING AND ENABLES STADIUMS
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT, JOBS AND AN
ECONOMIC, POSITIVE ECONOMIC
IMPACT. WITH LOS ANGELES HOSTING
THE OLYMPICS AND WORLD CUP, OUR
STADIUM AND ARENA INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL NEED UPDATING, BRINGING
MARKETING AGREEMENTS CLOSER TO
INDUSTRY STANDARDS WILL KEEP
STADIUMS MODERNIZED AND READY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THESE WORLD
EVENTS. SHE'S NOT HERE. I DID
HAVE, ANOTHER SPEAKER, BUT SHE'S
NOT HERE YET ANYWAY. WELL, WE'LL
SEE IF SHE SHOWS UP BY THE TIME
WE'RE FINISHING UP. THAT'S THE
PROBLEM WITH BEING RIGHT ON TIME
AND READY TO GO, WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS, SEE IF THERE IS
ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IN SUPPORT OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
95, SB 1488. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO, TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE. AS I SAID, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
WITH US TODAY. SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE. YES, WE'LL GO BACK.
WE'LL GO WE WILL GO BACK TO
TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT AND
WELCOME. HI. GOOD MORNING, ANGIE
MINETTI HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
DODGERS. CATCHING MY BREATH,
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF 14. YOU MIGHT
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN BETTER IF YOU
HAD NOT SAID THE DODGERS, BUT
JUST KNOW THAT I'M A DODGER FAN,
AND SO I'LL LET YOU PROCEED.
THANK YOU, SUPPORTIVE OF SB 1488
AS WE SUPPORT OUTDOOR
ADVERTISEMENTS. THIS HELPS US
DIVERSIFY REVENUE STREAMS AND
REDUCES OUR RELIANCE ON PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES. ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
AMENDMENTS COMING OUT OF SENATE
TRANSPORTATION AS THEY, DIRECT
THE STATE TO PRIORITIZE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING IN THE FUTURE FOR
FEDERAL STATE AGREEMENT
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE ELSE? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE? ONE
QUESTION. YES, SENATOR CIARDO,
THIS BILL ONLY COVERS THESE
LARGER PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
EXEMPTION THAT WILL HAVE THE
EXEMPTIONS. IT DOESN'T COVER THE
MOM AND POP SHOPS THAT ARE ALONG
THE SIDE OF THE FREEWAYS. NO,
THOSE EXEMPTIONS WON'T EXTEND TO
THE SMALLER COMPANIES. THE
CURRENT EXEMPTIONS ARE FOR,
ARENAS AND STADIUMS. YES. NOT
NOT SMALLER PROPERTIES. OKAY.
THIS WE JUST DEALING WITH WHAT
ALREADY IS AN EXEMPTION. WE'RE
NOT CREATING THE EXEMPTIONS.
IT'S WHAT ALREADY EXISTS. RIGHT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? SEEING NONE
WILL ALLOW YOU TO CONCLUDE. I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. BILL, THERE IS A MOTION BY
SENATOR WAHAB. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
AYE. CAFIERO. AYE. JONES. JONES.
NO ASHBY. HI. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. SATO WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE CARRIES OUT FIVE.
TWO. ONE. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO
1. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE ALL
SEVEN MEMBERS. SO THAT BILL IS
FINISHED AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE EARLY IN ORDER TO TAKE THAT
ONE UP. SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE BEGINNING OF THE
AGENDA. WE'LL START WITH SB 895
BY SENATOR ROTH. SENATOR ROTH
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANY ANYBODY
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 895? OKAY IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 895? SEEING NONE, THIS IS A
ELIGIBLE THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CABINET CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 895 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 902. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY,
SENATOR ROTH HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 902? IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 902?
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. I'M
ELIZABETH ROSE MAY AND I'M HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, THÀNH SB. 902
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB 899 BY SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR SKINNER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION THÀNH. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 899?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 899. I'M
ELIZABETH ROSE. MAY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO KNOW THAT
I'M A TWO TIME VIOLENT CRIME
SURVIVOR. SURVIVOR, AND I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION? AGAIN, THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 899 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 941 BY
SENATOR SKINNER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 941? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I MEAN, I'M SORRY, IN
OPPOSITION TO 941. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 941 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 976 BY
SENATOR SKINNER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 976? ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN IN OPPOSITION TO SB
976. AS THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
976 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
1077 BY SENATOR SKINNER. SHE HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1073?
ANYONE HERE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1073? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE. CANDIDATES
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1073 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1306 BY
SENATOR SKINNER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1306? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1306?
THIS AGAIN IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1306 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 913 BY SENATOR UMBERG.
SENATOR UMBERG HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 913? ANYONE IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 913? AGAIN,
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 913 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
914 BY SENATOR UMBERG IS THERE
IS. SENATOR UMBERG HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 914? ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO 914?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE. FILE
CANDIDATES. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 914 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 930 BY SENATOR
LAIRD, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 930? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY, ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 930? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE. CANDIDATES
FOR SB 930 WILL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1285 BY SENATOR
LAIRD, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1285? ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1285? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE.
FILE CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1285 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 938 BY
SENATOR CIERTO. 936 BY SENATOR
CIERTO. I WAS CHECKING TO SEE IF
HE WAS AWAKE. HE WAS AWAKE JUST
BARELY. I GOT AN ENERGY DRINK
GOING GOOD, SENATOR CIERTO HAS,
ALSO WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO, TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB 936? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 936? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 936 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 964 BY
SENATOR SATO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 964? ANYONE IN THE
ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 964? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 964 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 946 BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SENATOR MCGUIRE HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
946? ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 946?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 946 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 952 BY SENATOR
DOLLY. SENATOR DOLLY HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 952? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB 952. SB THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
952 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
1062 BY SENATOR DOLLY. SENATOR
DOLLY HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1062? MADAM CHAIR, GOOD MORNING,
CHRIS MCCAULEY ON BEHALF OF
HUMBOLDT REDWOOD COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AND THANK
SENATOR WAHAB FOR SHARING HER
COOKIES THIS MORNING. ABSOLUTELY
KEEPS US ALL HAPPY. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THAT MAYBE HE
DIDN'T GET A COOKIE BUT WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1062? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1062 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 954 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SENATOR
MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 954? THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 954?
THIS THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 954 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1057
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. 1057?
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1057? YES. THANK YOU. CHAIR
COMMITTEE AND STAFF RYAN MOORE
MUNI WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES, ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, AS WELL AS THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, SB 1057 AND THE
INTERESTS OF TIME. WE'VE
DETAILED IN OUR ANALYSIS THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF COUNTIES. AND
WE'LL ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT,
INCLUDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS, THE POTENTIAL
SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS.
DANIEL SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA, ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO SB 1057, AND WOULD, REITERATE
THE FISCAL ANALYSIS NOTED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION? SB 1057 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1057 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1124 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT. WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1124?
ANYONE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1124 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1142 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1142?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 1142, THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1142 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1323 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SENATOR
MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1323?
ANYONE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB 1323? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1323 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND SB 1497 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SENATOR
MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
1497. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
CRISTINA SCARINGE WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY,
PROUD SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT. I'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE
SUPPORT FOR THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. CLIMATE HAWKS
VOTE THE CENTER ON RACE,
POVERTY, AND THE ENVIRONMENT,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE, THE CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT, CALIFORNIA COALITION,
GREENPEACE USA, AND CLIMATE
ACTION CALIFORNIA. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME, I'LL JUST
REFERENCE THE THOROUGH COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND THANK THE STAFF FOR
THAT, AND ALSO REFERENCE THE
EXTENSIVE DOCUMENTATION WE FILED
FROM TOP ECONOMISTS, TOP LEGAL
SCHOLARS AND SCIENTISTS IN FAVOR
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING.
SAVANNAH JORGENSEN WITH THE
LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC
POLICY, CALIFORNIA, IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1497? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1497 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 966 BY SENATOR WIENER,
SENATOR WIENER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 966? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO 966? THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 966 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE SB
1012 BY SENATOR WIENER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1012?
ANYONE. IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1012. THIS BILL IS. A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1012 WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. SB
1031 BY SENATOR WIENER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION THÀNH ANYONE
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. SCOTT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO, THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
AND THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL. WORKERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1031? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1031 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 972 BY SENATOR MEN
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
972. MELISSA SPARKS KRANZ WITH
THE. LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES, THE SPONSORS OF AND IN
SUPPORT OF SB 972. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
972? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE.
FILE CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 972 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1221 BY SENATOR MEN
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION? IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1221? ANYONE IN THE ROOM TO
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. SCOTT. WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES,
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS, AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL. IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION? SB 1221 IS
THE SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, IT WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. SB 1242 BY SENATOR
MEN WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION?
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1242? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
, SB 1242 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 989 BY
SENATOR ASHBY. SENATOR ASHBY HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 989? GOOD MORNING.
PATRICIA HUNTER, VOLUNTEER WITH
SACRAMENTO FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER
AND MOTHER OF JOANNA HUNTER AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB 898
989? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 989 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1000 BY SENATOR
ASHBY. SENATOR ASHBY HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1000?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE. CANDIDATES ARE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1000 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1032 1035
BY SENATOR ASHBY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1035?
HOW ABOUT ANYBODY THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1035? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1035 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1477 BY SENATOR
ASHBY, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1477?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1477. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB
1477 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
1498 BY SENATOR ASHBY. SENATOR
ASHBY HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1498? OPPOSITION TO 1498. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE.
CANDIDATES. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1498 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB
990 BY SENATOR PADILLA, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 990 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1070 BY SENATOR
PADILLA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1070?
OPPOSITION TO 1070. THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1070 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1165 BY
SENATOR PADILLA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION THÀNH. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1165 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1178 BY
SENATOR PADILLA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1178 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1208 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. SENATOR PADILLA
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1208? HOW ABOUT ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1208? THIS AS
WELL AS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1208 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1228 BY SENATOR
PADILLA, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
OAN. THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1228 WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. SB 1351 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. SENATOR BAILEY
AGAIN HAS WAIVED. PRESENTATION
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
1351? HOW ABOUT TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO 1351? THIS BILL IS
THE SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1351 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1002 BY SENATOR BLAKESWARE
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
1002? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING. I'M ELIZABETH ROSEMAY,
THIS BILL IS DISTURBING, AND I'M
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO IT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1002?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1002 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1038 BY SENATOR
BLAKE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1038? HOW ABOUT
IN OPPOSITION TO 1038? GOOD
MORNING. I'M ELIZABETH ROSEMAY,
AND I HAVE MY CCW, AND I ALSO
HUNT. AND THIS BILL JUST PUTS A
REAL HEAVY REQUIREMENT ON TO
RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNERS. SO I'M
HERE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1038 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1045 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1045?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO 1045?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1045 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1236. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL? IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1236 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1302 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1302
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1013
BY SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR
BRADFORD HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, AND I THANK YOU.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE SENATOR
BRADFORD WANTS TO PRESENT BUT
BUT HE'S NOT MOVING. SO I'M
GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
SITUATION. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1013. WELCOME HE'S
JUST JOKING. YES. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS DARLENE CRUMMEY, A
MEMBER OF THE COALITION FOR A
JUST AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA
KGEC. AS WELL AS THE AMERICAN
REDRESS COALITION. CALIFORNIA
AUKE BAY AREA I AM STRONG, I AM
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB 1013.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING. APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. I'M KIM MIMS HERE
WITH COALITION FOR JUSTICE AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA KGEC
AMERICAN REDRESS COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA ARC SACRAMENTO, C
AND AMEND THE MASS MEDIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF 1013. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? SB 1013 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1013 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. HOW ABOUT SB
1050 BY SENATOR BRADFORD AGAIN,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION? IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? YES. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN. DARLENE
CROMARTIE, A MEMBER OF KGEC AS
WELL AS ARK BAY AREA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? HELLO AGAIN. I'M KIM
MIMS WITH KGEC ARC SACRAMENTO
AND AMEND THE MASS MEDIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB 1050. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1050
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB 1109 BY SENATOR BRADFORD,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? YES,
DARLING CROMARTIE, I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? YES. KIM MIMS IN
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, 1109 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1292 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? YES, DARLING.
CROMARTIE INFO. SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE? YES. KIM MIMS,
ALSO IN FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
? IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1292 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1331
BY SENATOR BRADFORD, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1331? YES.
GOOD MORNING DARLING. COMMITTEE,
A MEMBER OF CSEC AND ARK BAY
AREA, I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB
1331. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO. KIM MIMS WITH CSEC, ARK
SACRAMENTO AND AMEND THE MASS
MEDIA IN FULL SUPPORT OF 1331.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? SB 1331 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1331 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1054 BY SENATOR
RUBIO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1054 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1060 BY SENATOR BECKER WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SB 1063 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1060 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1206 BY
SENATOR BECKER. SENATOR BECKER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? BUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1206
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1071
BY SENATOR DODD, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1071 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1159 BY
SENATOR DODD. ANYONE IN SUPPORT?
YES, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS MCCAULEY,
ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT, REDWOOD
COMPANY AND MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANY, BOTH IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I NEGLECTED TO
SAY THAT HE WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1159 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1074 BY
SENATOR JONES. SENATOR JONES HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. THANK THANK
HIM FOR THAT. AND HE WAS MOVING
FAST TOO. IS THERE ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1074
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB 1087 BY SENATOR GROVE.
SENATOR GROVE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1087 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1239 BY
SENATOR GROVE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1239 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1264 BY
SENATOR GROVE. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE. SENATOR GROVE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE. OH, I'M SORRY, IT
WAS MOVING TOO FAST. WELCOME HI,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, TALLY
D'AMATO, ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
NORMAL, ORIGINAL SPONSORS OF AB
2188, CORK. IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 1264? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1264
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1414
BY SENATOR GROVE, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1414? AND MY
NAME IS HELEN TAYLOR, AND I'M
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL ANTI-TRAFFICKING
ORGANIZATION EXODUS CRY IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MIKE MURRAY WITH THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? SB 1414 IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1414 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1100 BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. SENATOR
PORTANTINO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1100 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1128 BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT, NOT IN OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
, SB 1128 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1147 BY SENATOR PORTANTINO,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1147 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1114 BY
SENATOR NILO. SENATOR NILO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, 1114 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1176 BY
SENATOR NILO, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION
? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, 1176 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1135 BY SENATOR
LIMÓN. IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? SENATOR LIMÓN OBVIOUSLY HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1135 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. 1152 BY
SENATOR LEHMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF 1152. GOOD MORNING, AMANDA
WALDRUM WITH CAL BROADBAND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES OR
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1152 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. 1130 I'M
SORRY. 1304 BY SENATOR LEHMAN.
SENATOR LEHMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1304 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1433 BY
SENATOR LEHMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE IN THE ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1433 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1202 BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1202 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1387 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
, SB 1387 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
SB 1416 BY SENATOR NEWMAN, WHO
WAS WAIVED. PRESENTATION THÀNH
ANYONE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1416 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1256 BY SENATOR GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1256 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1287 BY SENATOR GLAZER. HE
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? CLIFF BERG,
REPRESENTING THE JEWISH PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE, JPAC,
REPRESENTING OVER 33 STATEWIDE
AND REGIONAL JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA,
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL,
WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO FIGHTING
ANTI-SEMITISM IN HIGHER
EDUCATION CAMPUSES IN OUR STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? YES. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS DAVID
MANDEL, A LONGTIME ACTIVE WITH
THE ACTIVE CHAPTER LEADER WITH
JEWISH VOICE FOR PEACE AND
ACTIVE ON THE NATIONAL LEVEL AS
WELL. I'M STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS VERY DANGEROUS BILL AND
POTENTIALLY WASTE WASTEFUL OF
IMMENSE AMOUNTS OF STATE, OF
STATE FUNDING. IT PURPORTS TO
FURTHER REGULATE SPEECH ON
HIGHER EDUCATION CAMPUSES IN A
WAY THAT, FOR THE MOST PART,
ONLY RESTATES WHAT IS ALREADY
EXISTING LAW, AND IS LIMITED, OF
COURSE, BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT
AND THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
OAN, IT TALKS ABOUT, VIOLENCE,
INTIMIDATION, HARASSMENT, WHICH
ARE ALREADY LONG LITIGATED CARVE
OUTS FROM, FROM THE LAW
REGARDING FREE SPEECH. BUT THEY
CAN'T BE FURTHER ENHANCED. IT
ALSO, IT ADDS ONE VERY DANGEROUS
TWIST, WHICH SAYS THAT IT
PROHIBITS CALLING FOR GENOCIDE
THAT CROSSES THE LINE INTO
VIEWPOINT DISCRIMINATION AS
ODIOUS AS ANY CALL FOR GENOCIDE
IS TO ALL OF US, I'M SURE THAT
IT'S A VERY SUBJECTIVE,
DETERMINATION AS TO WHAT
CONSTITUTES A CALL FOR GENOCIDE.
VERY MUCH IN DEBATE AS WE SPEAK
THESE DAYS. AND THIS WOULD WOULD
BE ANYONE WHO TRIES ANY
UNIVERSITY THAT TRIES TO ENFORCE
THIS LAW WOULD PROBABLY BE
SUBJECT TO LITIGATION. THE STATE
WOULD HAVE TO DEFEND IT,
POTENTIALLY VERY EXPENSIVE. AND
IT CONTRADICTS THE PROHIBITION
ON VIEWPOINT DISCRIMINATION IN
THE FIRST AMENDMENT. AND
FINALLY, THE REAL AGENDA BEHIND
THIS BILL IS TO CONFLATE
CRITICISM OF ISRAEL WITH
ANTI-SEMITISM, THIS BILL WILL
NOT PROTECT JEWS OR ANYBODY
ELSE. IT WILL. IT SERVES AS A
BULLY TO TRY TO SUPPRESS SPEECH
AND SUPPORT OF PALESTINIAN HUMAN
RIGHTS, OF WHICH I VERY MUCH AM,
AND I SPEAK NOT ONLY AS AN
AMERICAN JEW, BUT ALSO AS AN
ISRAELI WHO LIVED THERE FOR TEN
YEARS, AND I, THEREFORE WOULD
URGE YOU TO WELL, YOU PROBABLY
MOVE TO SUSPENSE, BUT I WOULD
URGE YOU TO DEFEAT THIS BILL AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1282, I
MEAN, 1287. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WE'LL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1327
BY SENATOR GLAZER. HE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 1327? HOW ABOUT
OPPOSITION TO 1327? THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1327 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1365 BY
SENATOR GLAZER. HE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1365 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1424 BY
SENATOR GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
1424? HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION TO
1424? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1424 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1430 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
, SB 1430 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1462 BY SENATOR GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1462 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1282 BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF 1282?
HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB 1282? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1282 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1338 BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION? IS
THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1338
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1340
BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS,
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1340 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1293 BY SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH
SENATOR OCHOA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
? THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1293 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1303 BY SENATOR CAVALLERO. I
HAVE WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1303 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1390 BY
SENATOR CAVALLERO, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB 1390 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1420 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. SENATOR
CABALLERO'S WAY PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? MADAM CHAIR
CHRIS MCCAULEY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RENEWABLE
TRANSPORTATION ALLIANCE AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND HOPEFUL THAT
THE CHAIR WILL RELEASE THIS BILL
OFF THE SUSPENSE FILE ON
THURSDAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF
US? IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
JONATHAN KHÓ, CLIMATE ACTION,
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL PROMOTES THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HYDROGEN FROM HIGH CARBON
FEEDSTOCKS THAT WOULD CONTINUE
OUR DEVELOPMENT, OUR DEPENDANCE
ON FOSSIL FUELS, AND IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? THIS THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1420 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB 1321 BY
SENATOR WAHAB, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION BUT BROUGHT
COOKIES, WHICH IS ALWAYS A GOOD
THING. IS THERE ANYONE HERE? WHO
WOULD SHE. SO IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1321 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1330 BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. SENATOR
ARCHULETA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1330
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1421
BY SENATOR STERN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR CLIFF BERG, ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE, WHICH REPRESENTS OVER
33 DIFFERENT STATEWIDE AND
REGIONAL JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING THE LÀ
FEDERATION, ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE, SACRAMENTO FEDERATION,
SACRAMENTO JCRC, SILICON VALLEY,
AMERICAN JEWISH COMMITTEE, ALL
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL, WHICH
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE IN
FIGHTING ANTI-SEMITISM. BUT ALSO
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE LIKE
SENATOR GLASER'S IN FIGHTING
HATRED IN EDUCATIONAL CAMPUSES.
WHATEVER OUR KIND OF HATRED, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT ANTI-SEMITISM
AND ANTI-GAY ANTI-LATINO
ANTI-AFRICAN-AMERICAN THÀNH.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE SEEN A
RISE IN HATE SPEECH, HATE
ACTIVITY, HATE CRIMES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THIS LEGISLATION IS
URGENTLY NEEDED AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1421 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1444 BY SENATOR
STERN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1444 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1504 BY SENATOR
STERN. SENATOR STERN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT CLIFF
BERGERE ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE AND 33
JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, FOR THE REASONS I
ARTICULATED. AND SENATOR GLAZER
AND SENATOR STERN'S OTHER BILL,
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1504 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1508 BY
SENATOR STERN. SENATOR STERN HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? BUT HOW
ABOUT IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1508
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB 1460 BY SENATOR DURAZO. IS
THERE ANYONE SENATOR DURAZO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL? IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN IN OPPOSITION. THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1460 WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. WE'VE ALREADY
DISPENSED WITH SB 1488, SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO SB 1500 BY SENATOR
DURAZO. SENATOR DURAZO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON THIS
BILL. IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? HOW ABOUT ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1500 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SB 1461 BY SENATOR ALAN. SENATOR
ALAN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1461 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST, SB 1474 BY SENATOR
ALAN, WHO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF 1474? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO 1474?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1474 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
SO THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
FOR TODAY. LET ME THANK
EVERYBODY FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING. WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND THE
MEETING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATION IS ADJOURNED. I
WORK ALL RIGHT. YOU'RE LOOKING
ALL